i feel like one of the things that
people and look like here i am going
mom or dad like you know my childhood
trauma and they're like oh
they're like i didn't beat you i didn't
you know what you know i didn't you know
whatever like there's so many things
that come up when you tell somebody like
i have trauma and i think that it's the
education
of the word trauma that needs to be
uh absolutely emphasized and promoted
everywhere because it's it's not what
most people think it is so that's
accurate like explain trauma
um to everyone sure so i feel like
whenever i i i obviously am a trauma
expert so i get asked about it a lot but
i feel like when you start talking about
trauma it's like let's talk about cancer
you know or something like that so it's
like not exactly like an exciting topic
but it can become exciting because when
you do your trauma work which i'll
define it in a second but i want to give
some context
when you really understand what trauma
is and then you do your trauma work like
your life improves significantly like it
really does because like you start to
feel better your mental health improves
your relationships improve finances
improve and that's just not hyperbole
like there's like so much data like
peer-reviewed metadata now across many
different spectrums and populations to
suggest that trauma work is so valuable
it hasn't made its way into the
mainstream american psychiatric
association's dsm diagnosis yet
unfortunately
but
when you look at what trauma is right
i've i'm a nmd which is not a medical
doctor okay that's what i am okay so i
don't have any credentials i don't have
any certifications in fact i have one
certification in yoga from yoga works
which is now bankrupt so my bet
certification is like no good anymore
right so it's like it's like uh but i
have like 20 000 hours working with
people uh over a decade plus
and we've gotten incredible outcomes
with people um and we're starting to
pre-clinical trials in our work to
document the efficacy so we can start to
publish papers on it
but
when you look at what trauma is there's
so many definitions depending on who you
talk to right you talk to like a
standard psychiatrist or psychologist
they'll give you one definition you talk
to neuroscientists they'll give you a
different definition um you talk to you
know someone like bethel vanderkult
he'll give you a certain definition or
you know dr bruce perry amazing he'll
give you a definition dr steven portrays
all these people give you different
definitions and they're all in the right
direction so what i've basically done is
try to summarize in a way that people
can understand
and it's a little verbose but i'll do my
best to say it slowly okay
so trauma and emotional trauma is any
experience of threat
disconnection
isolation or immobilization that's
important understand it's threat
disconnection isolation or mobilization
that
disregulates
the optimal functioning
of your body of your health of your
immune system of your nervous system of
your spirit of your brain of your
emotional body right um and it has to
have a long-term effect it's not
something that happens like momentarily
when you move on so if you have a
dysregulated nervous system immune
system endocrine system uh emotional
system brain
uh
body
uh emotions mind spirit any of those
things not operating functionally and
optimally then you are most likely in
some type of emotional trauma response
because our goal is to be
optimal functioning and to be able to
experience adverse experiences but then
like creatures in nature like shake it
off and then proceed in the present
moment right but when we get stuck and
when we're in anxiety or depression uh
perfectionism you know go down the list
of all the emotions right and then all
the different diagnoses are out there
ptsd the id ocd all the ds right those
are all trauma responses and so it's so
much more than a physical injury people
think that it has to be a dramatic
physical injury that that's traumatic
that's blunt force trauma or a capital t
trauma but trauma can be
you know your parents weren't
emotionally in tune with you right
there's a difference between physical
survival needs and emotional needs right
so you have your physical needs met and
still be traumatized because your
emotional needs weren't met
right
and it's an emotional game so like with
physical trauma um you know you see
bruises you can see things right um but
with emotional trauma like they're it's
it's invisible now you can you can get
data from the nervous system and from
the body now we can kind of start to
measure these things but it's still a
newer science it's a softer science but
it's more or less invisible but it shows
up in
behaviors that help us not move forward
to achieve goals not operate
functionally defiance rebellion all
those different things so if you're in
any of those responses the likelihood
that there's emotional trauma there are
significantly high and and also there's
a a big correlation now between
emotional trauma and chronic disease
right so if you look at most chronic no
one catches diabetes or no one catches
fibromyalgia you catch covid right but
that's an infectious disease but you
don't catch fibromyalgia
and or you know uh endometriosis or
whatever right there's so many different
chronic illnesses and what's really
interesting is the world's leading
functional medicine doctors
um are starting to see sometimes
correlation and sometimes causation
between emotional trauma and chronic
illness and that sounds like like almost
like victim blaming like my thoughts
craig gave me cancer or something like
that but that's not exactly the take the
take is when you have emotional or
nervous system or immune or endocrine
dysregulation it makes your body more
susceptible to pathogens
right and so the pathogen will enter the
body and then sort of metastasize or
nest or start to materialize in the
areas of most susceptibility which is
why when you look at for example certain
cancers everybody has cancer for the
most part the reason why someone gets
cancer that's like you know
life-threatening is because the immune
system doesn't recognize as a threat
anymore and you have to look at why is
that yes environmental toxins are the
main cause of cancer genetic cancers are
very small percentage of cancers but
when you look at like what body did this
cancer enter
right and what was going on in its
nervous system and immune system and
endocrine system
and you realize that well the state of
that person's body and immune system
endocrine system was dysregulated
because of an emotionally traumatic
experience then they're more at risk to
be able to get chronic illness right
so it's not a blame the victim situation
but you know just like with kovid covet
is a metabolic disease right if you are
metabolically healthy the likelihood
you're gonna get it or be hurt by is
very low right and so the same thing is
true for a lot of chronic illnesses is
that like we get chronic illness and the
reason why it shows up in certain areas
is because that's the earth needs our
attention
right so there's a lot of it's not that
it's like okay just do your trauma work
like you got to do your functional
medicine work you got to do allopathic
stuff you those things are important but
it's the emotional components that we're
missing but we're starting to see it now
and so there's a direct correlation
between those things so that was a very
long answer to your question but i tried
to give them as much context as i could